this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 42 sitting here with Echo Charles
and DC Daryl Cooper guest appearance
I was
I was thinking about some of the
principles of combat leadership that I
talk about all the time one of them is
prioritized and execute and the reason I
was thinking about this is because
obviously I talk about it a lot from a
business perspective I talk about it a
lot from a combat leadership perspective
and sometimes I talk about it from a
life perspective and I think it is it's
well not a thing I know it's applicable
in all those categories it is absolutely
applicable in all those categories but
there's something else that in talking
with people and communicating with
people I've talked to a lot of people
and communicate with a lot of people in
a lot of different situations and
scenarios and one of those
is I I talk to people that are dealing
with
like a bunch of different issues
sometimes
emotional type issues sometimes
traumatic type issues and because of
this is interesting you know I always
say in combat because of Murphy's Law
your problems are going to hit you at
the same time in business
because of Murphy's Law all your
problems are going to hit you at the
same time so you're going to get the
client that's mad the factory that's on
fire the the supply chain that's broken
it's all going to happen at the same
time in combat you're going to get
somebody wounded you're going to have a
bad head count you're going to have a
civilian steel you're gonna have all
these things happening at the same time
and in life same thing you're going to
have your water heater break you're
going to have your kid sick you're gonna
have look all this stuff Murphy's law
but this also happens
on a on an emotional level too so I talk
to people and sometimes I see that they
are under an emotional attack
and because of Murphy's Law
it's an emotional attack from multiple
different directions
and what I wanted to talk about is the
fact that even in those situations
prioritize and execute still comes into
play so when you have multiple emotional
traumatic scenarios happening at the
same time
this your reaction
can be the same as someone messing up on
the battlefield that is they freeze they
they freeze they don't do anything or
they try and solve all the things at the
same time same thing can happen in the
business I don't know what to do what
should I focus on and they don't do
anything or they try and solve all their
problems at the same time life the same
thing can happen so when we as humans
get hit with multiple emotional attacks
or like psychological attacks you know
it's like you lost your job you lost
your girlfriend you found out that
you've got some sickness that's going on
and all those three things happen at the
same time look if one of them happens
you lose your job you got your girl
you're okay you lose your girl you still
go to work you got your job you're okay
but when you lose both those things
that's a huge hit to your to your
emotional stability
and then on top of that you find out
that you're sick and then on top of that
you know the the mortgage is due and now
you're a couple days late so these are
like problems but they're not just
they're not just normal problems they're
emotional problems and they hit you at
an emotional level so
in those situations
prioritize and execute still applies and
I've talked some people through this
recently who have had some significant
emotional challenges going on
and it's the same it's the same
principle okay what is the major cause
of your problem
okay you've got a bunch of problems
going on you've got this one major
significant problem
let's talk through that problem first
let's focus on
coming to grips with that initial
problem because you combine six problems
this is how people get overwhelmed this
is how people end up hurting themselves
killing themselves because there's six
problems they they they're just
overwhelmed and they say I can't I'm
never gonna get out of this
same thing on the battlefield you got
all these problems going on no one
leader doesn't know what to do they
freeze they don't do anything they think
oh I'm overwhelmed
so when you have five six seven
emotional things that are dragging you
down
prioritize and execute okay what's the
biggest issue that I have right now
how can I start to address that what can
I do to get to a better place with that
particular issue
now there is
whenever I talk about prioritize next
year I talk about handling the biggest
problem first that is one technique for
prioritize next you there's another
technique that is also effective
depending on the scenario sometimes you
got 10 problems
and you got one you know the biggest
problem is this the next biggest problem
is that but you got a couple little
straggler problems that aren't that big
you can actually go you know what I'm
gonna get rid of this problem right now
I'm gonna focus on this for the next two
hours get it done get it taken care of
Boom then I can go to the problem that's
going to take three hours get that one
off my plate so you actually can then
focus on these big problems that might
take you a week two weeks three weeks a
month to get solved but you've gotten
rid of some of those smaller problems so
you could do that technique as well
the the principle is the same as
prioritize and execute but the technique
is maybe you go after the small problems
first or ones that are going to be
easier for you to handle you know you
you you got a sick cat
and it's draining you emotionally
because your cat's gonna die and it's a
problem and you're crying every night
well you know what the solution is let's
kill the cat I mean quite honestly yes
right you gotta you got a cat that needs
to be put down and it's dragging you
down you might need to say okay you know
what
I need to do the right thing here my cat
is suffering my cat has no there's no
medical viable option
I need to I need to do the right thing
and get my cap put down boom so you get
that off your plate that could also be
the biggest problem I mean in some cases
but
the point is it doesn't really matter if
you use the first technique or the
second technique
you could even just look at hey this is
the one that I
here's another way to do it this is the
biggest problem that I'm most scared of
facing so I am either gonna tackle that
one
I'm going to tackle that problem you
know I'm I'm having an existential
crisis and I'm afraid to die okay maybe
you say all right you know what I'm
gonna sit down I'm gonna talk to my I'm
going to read I'm going to talk to my
friend you know Echo who seems to have a
good handle on this kind of stuff I'm
gonna try and overcome this fear or
maybe say you know what that's a huge
problem I don't want to deal with that
one right now I'm gonna go to this other
thing that's been bothering me which is
you know I don't know if I'm in the
right career
so
both those things work now the other
part of this
is
is taking action taking action is a is a
starting to move in the right direction
starting to move
starts to solve problems and it starts
to solve emotional problems as well when
you sit and or you lay you lay down or
you sit and you stay static and you
don't move this is not good look are
there exceptional times where maybe you
need to take a tactical pause and you
need to maintain your position for a
little while to let a situation develop
yes yes it does happen
seven out of ten times action is going
to Trump in action
so let your default mode be hey I've got
these five or six emotionally draining
situations happening
when you're just sitting there they're
continuing to drain don't do that
get up start to move start to figure out
how you're going to address some of
these problems and what makes it
digestible is that instead of looking at
the nine problems that you have which
you can't address nine things at once
you can't you can barely even comprehend
nine things at once
but when you look at them you go all
right I got all these things that are
bothering me what is the biggest okay oh
my cat is freaking sick it's been
bothering me all right I need to address
that right now
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs 8.18
cents a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance Jocko underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you immobilized
Underground